hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about scramblaces which play an
important role in membrane function
and then at the end of the video i'm
going to talk a little bit about a
special kind of protein that sometimes
uh classified as a scramblace called
biogenic clefaces so be looking out for
that at the end
so let's go ahead and get started
basically the the point of this video
and another video that i'm posting is to
talk about enzymes that catalyze a
special kind of diffusion
of phospholipids across biological
membranes
and the type of diffusion that they do
is called trans
verb
diffusion sometimes this is referred to
as
flip flop diffusion
so right here
i've got a drawing of a of a biological
membrane in this case we're going to
call it the plasma membrane remember
that these membranes are
studded with proteins so they've got
transmembrane proteins like the flip
faces flop bases and scramblaces that
we're talking about right now
and they've also got two
faces or two leaflets
that make up this phospholipid bilayer
remember bi and bilayer means two so
there is basically an exoplasmic face of
lipids that's on the outside
and then a cytoplasmic face of the
plasma membrane is on the inside so like
touching the cytoplasm
and so the the
phospholipids in these membranes they
can diffuse laterally very easily that
means just moving
back and forth
in you know all staying in the same face
whatever face they're in diffusing um
around that face whether it be the
exoplasmic face or the cytoplasmic face
what these guys do
these
enzymes they catalyze flip-flop or
transverse diffusion so that's moving
from one face
to another face so either from the
exoplasmic face to the cytoplasmic face
that's what flip bases do or from the
cytoplasmic face to the exoplasmic face
that's what flaw do i have another video
you know the star right here that goes
into flip faces and flop bases in a lot
more detail so be sure to check that one
out
um
but all of these enzymes particularly
the flip basis and block bases you know
they catalyze this diffusion really to
maintain
membrane
asymmetry
and what that means is that with these
biological membranes
you know all of these phospholipids
they're not all the same there's a lot
of different kinds of phospholipids um
phosphatidylserine phosphatidylcholine
phosphatidyl ethanol ethanol amine um
single myelin uh cholesterol right well
cholesterol is a steroid on a
phospholipid but the point is that
there's a lot of different uh
lipids
in this bilayer some of them are much
more frequent in the exoplasmic face
some are much more frequent in the
cytoplasmic face and the having the
right frequencies the right
phospholipids on the right sides of that
membrane is really important for
membrane function so that's what we call
membrane asymmetry having like different
phospholipids in different places
basically on in one leaflet versus
another leaflet and so these enzymes
help to maintain that now these enzymes
are trans membrane right the flip faces
the flop bases the scram blazes they
span the membrane that makes them trans
membrane proteins and their lipid
transporters so they're transporting
phospholipids from one side to another
now these may be highly specific
meaning that they may only transport
like one kind of
uh one kind of phospholipid or they may
transport multiple types it just kind of
depends on which protein you're talking
about
but really importantly they provide a
way for hydrophilic heads to move across
the hydrophobic bilayer middle and i've
kind of got that
illustrated up here so here we've got a
membrane this right here what i've drawn
is a scramblace
scramblaces are calcium dependent as
we'll see in a minute but in order for
uh
this scramblace in in this instance to
move phospholipids from one side of the
membrane to another side meaning from
like the exoplasmic side on the outside
to the cytoplasmic side on the inside or
vice versa they they do so
by providing a mechanism through which
this you know hydrophilic so these all
of these head groups you see the little
green dash that's a minus sign a
negative sign
and so these
heads both the ones that are down here
and the ones that are up here
they are very polar
very hydrophilic so i'm going to write
that right here
these heads are hydrophilic remember
that's water loving
and very polar
so they like to
interact with water and other polar
things
on the other hand those fatty acid tails
that are in the middle of the bilayer
that are part of those phospholipids
those are very water fearing remember
that means that they are hydrophobic
and non-polar
and these things yeah they're like water
and oil right they don't like to mix so
thermodynamically that is not favored
so
really you know all of these types but
here we're talking about scrub laces and
in particular the scramblaces
offer a way for these negatively charged
uh
negatively charged phospholipid heads
to be able to cross to flip-flop to
transversely diffuse from one side to
the other side
um through that very hydrophobic
nonpolar barrier
so that's kind of what the mechanism
looks like
now let's keep talking about scramblaces
in humans there are five different
scramblaces we call them
hplscr1
through i should have a little h right
here too through
hplscr5 so five different ones they have
differential expression between tissues
some of them are expressed in lots of
different tissues
whereas for example hplcr2
has only been found to be expressed in
the male testis
so
differential expressions between tissues
and then scrambling
they're distinct from flip faces and
flaw bases so again if you're interested
in flip faces and flaw pieces see my
other video on that but the scram laces
they've got some different
characteristics
first of all they're energy independent
they do not
require atp
so flip aces and flop bases they have
atp hydrolysis that's like an energy
investment from the cell
to
drive forward their action for them to
do their job
on the other hand scramblace is energy
independent no atp hydrolysis required
on the other hand scramblacies are
calcium dependent so the scramblace
complexes
they have
a calcium ion binding domain for those
of you interested in protein domains
it's like an ef hand like domain but
anyways it binds calcium
now normally at like a resting sort of
normal state of the cell
normally
there's low calcium in the cells and
this means since calcium i'll circle
that right there since calcium binding
is necessary for the scramblace to
function if there's low calcium in the
cells there tends to be
low scramblace activity now remember
that the
i talked earlier about this membrane
asymmetry and how important it is that
certain
phospholipids be
very frequent in the exoplasmic face and
other phospholipids be very frequent in
the cytoplasmic face
well scramblace i mean the way that it
works is by
scrambling
these phospholipids moving them in in
either direction so that's called
bi-directional moving from
outside to the inside or from the inside
face to the outside face
and so
one of the
ways this happens or is triggered is
through increased cytosolic calcium so
when you get
an increase i'm going to have some up
arrows right there when you get some
increase in calcium ions in the
cytosolic the inside
compartment of the cell you also get
increased
scramblace activity
and so what it does is it scrambles
these negatively
charged phospholipids
bi-directionally
remember flip faces and flop bases uh
one direction only flip base is going
from
exoplasmic phase to cytoplasmic face
flaw bases moving things in the opposite
direction
scram blazes either direction
bi-directional
so scramble these negatively charged
phospholipids
giving them a pathway to be able to
cross through that hydrophobic fatty
acid
tail portion of the bilayer
and and then be
basically flipped to the other side
so this scrambles mediated transport is
particularly
important there's a few different
um
phenomena i guess you could say cellular
phenomena where we where we see this a
lot and one
is with the
um
with the phospholipid phosphatidylserine
so
phosphatidylserine
gets transported
from the inside cytosolic or cytoplasmic
leaflet to the exoplasmic leaflet now
it's important that you realize that
about 96
of phosphatidylserine
is usually in the inside leaflet okay so
like in the cytoplasmic face
um so usually 96 of this on the inside
but
scrambling mediated transport scrambles
moving phosphatidylserine
from the inner leaflet to the outer
leaflet
is an early step in a process known as
apoptosis
and maybe you've heard of this apoptosis
is programmed cell
death it is the
regulated organized
breakdown and death of a cell and it's a
normal part
of functioning in multicellular
organisms
and so
having that phosphatidylserine
suddenly appearing at much higher
frequencies on the outside of the cell
that actually is an early step in
apoptosis and it signals
to
uh basically passing immune cells called
macrophages
to engulf
and and kill the cell and this is a way
that
um that like old or damaged cells can be
broken down and their parts recycled
basically
so that is scramblacies
i now want to take a minute to talk
about a different
class
of these
transmembrane lipid transporter proteins
and those are known as
biogenic
flip aces and i talk a little bit more
about biogenic flip bases in my video on
flip bases and flop bases and the reason
i bring them up here
is because even though they are
often called flip aces
they are sometimes classified as
scramblaces in other words depending on
where you're reading about them what
source you're using sometimes they'll be
referred to as flip bases and sometimes
they'll be called scramblaces
now
why is this why are they sometimes
called scramblaces well they have some
things in common with scramblaces you
know they are atp independent remember
that flip faces hydrolyze atp they
require atp to do their job
whereas these
lipid transporter proteins are atp
independent no atp required like
scramblacies they're also bi-directional
remember
scramblaces
i think you can see it best here
scramblaces are moving phospholipids in
either direction in both directions
whereas flip bases only moving from the
exoplasmic to the cytoplasmic side of
the membrane
so in this way the biogenic flip bases
are very similar to scramblacies
but then in other ways they're not very
similar to scrambling scramblacies they
are constitutively active so they're not
activated through this like calcium
binding domain
they also even though they're
bi-directional moving things in either
direction across the membrane
they are
really
especially important for movement in us
in a particular direction
and that is because phospholipids that
are made in the endoplasmic reticulum in
the lumen of the endoplasmic reticulum
um or in the bacterial plasma membrane
they have to be
moved they have to be moved from the
basically from the er lumen to the
cytoplasmic side
um and that is very similar to what you
know
basically regular flip bases do moving
from
from from one from from the original
destination from the original location
sorry from the original location to the
cytoplasmic side
biogenic bases are moving from the er
lumen to
the cytoplasmic side i should probably
write that right here er lumen
2
the
cytoplasmic or cytosolic
side
okay
or if they're in bacterial plasma
membranes to the outer leaflet
um and i guess i want to say one more
thing this word right here
biogenic
this is referring to
membranes
where
where where membrane is being created or
synthesized so particularly in the
endoplasmic reticulum also the golgi
apparatus and eukaryotic cells
this is where our membranes are being
made being synthesized so that's why
it's called biogenic
so we are talking about the lipid
transporters that are
playing a role in those biogenic
membranes in the er
so
if you want to learn more i know i've
already mentioned that video on flip
faces and flaw bases
i also have a video on membrane
asymmetry and sightedness if you want to
learn more about
you know which phospholipids are present
on either side and how that happens and
why it's important
and i guess otherwise that's it for
today so thank you so much for watching
biology professor please please please
make sure that you subscribe hit the
subscribe button hit the bell to get
notifications and good luck studying i
will see you next time thanks guys